Тоді ми билися, віддавалися свої життя, здоров’я
за 100 метрів землі, за 200, за один гектар, грубо кажучи.
Зараз війна збільшилася до того, що ми за тисячі гектарів воюємо.
Коли ракети прилітали по пологових будинках, по школах і так далі,
по цивільному населенню, я розумів, що це планомірне знищення нашої нації.
І тут немає нічого іншого, як іти в епіцентр бою і захищати, стримувати.
Або ми виживемо, або нас усіх вб’ють.
Я Кашпур Роман на псевдо "Скіф".
У 2016 році у складі добровольчого українського корпусу "Правий сектор"
добровольцем відправився на схід нашої країни -
боронити та захищати її цілісність та незалежність.
Як запитав у мене мій командир:
"Чого ти сюди прийшов такий молодий?"
І я йому кажу: "За справедливістю".
В АТО з 2016-го,
потім у 2017-му я ухвалив рішення підписати контракт.
Це була спеціалізація розвідка.
Я відчував ті два роки, які я пропустив не на війні,
з 2014-го року, я відчував за собою гризіння совісті.
Тому що хлопці реально воювали,
реально клали своє життя, здоров’я, а я там відсиджувався десь в університеті.
І тому мені потрібно було туди, де гарячіше, де запекліше.
Розвідка - це завжди попереду.
Тобто це те, що мені потрібно, те, чого я шукав.
Це очі, вуха фронту, руки.
За нулем – це місце, де відкривається вся сутність людини.
Кожен вихід – це, як я завжди називав, 50 на 50.
Тому що ніколи не знаєш, що там.
Це було 16 травня 2019 року, на День вишиванки.
Я цього не забуду ніколи в житті.
Як мені потім говорили: пощастило, народився у вишиванці.
Ми проробляли, дорозвідували шлях до їхніх позицій.
Коли вже група почала відходити, я буквально встиг зробити пів кроку.
Стався вибух. Мене збило з ніг, підкинуло.
Відразу, як тільки впав, я подивився на ногу
і, в принципі, стало все зрозуміло. Підрив.
Навіть у голові усвідомлення того: "Ну, сьогодні я.
Ти ж сам розумів, Рома, на що ти йдеш,
на що ти підписуєшся, що це за робота і що може бути в перспективі".
Ще від перших хвилин підриву і потім до всього курсу реабілітації
я жив з однією думкою, що потрібно набратися терпіння і чекати на протез.
Тут головне бажання, все в голові.
Я хотів бігати, я хотів жити повноцінно
i в мене це виходить по цей день.
Тому що в мене є бажання жити.
Я не вважаю, що ампутація – це якийсь вирок, а протез – це обмеження.
Це така сама кінцівка, просто штучна.
До моменту, ще коли я був без ноги,
без протезу навіть,
я свято вірив, що тільки-тільки встану,
приміряю протез і повернуся до хлопців воювати.
І з командиром у мене були хороші стосунки,
з Колодяжним.
Я думаю, що він би погодився.
Але через місяць після мого підриву,
після спецоперації по Цемаху в Мар`їнці,
він загинув.
І, знаєте, тоді це був для мене такий стоп-момент з приводу війни.
Прийшло усвідомлення, що, можливо,
потрібно щось спробувати інше в цьому житті.
Тим більше, що мені на той момент був 21 рік.
Почалися думки про сім’ю, про дітей.
На четвертий день після поранення,
коли мене з реанімації перевели вже в травматологію,
в палату, де можна пускати відвідувачів,
дзвонить телефон, я піднімаю слухавку, такий приємний жіночий голос:
"Привіт, я Юля, волонтер з Харкова.
Мене попросив твій командир Дракон,
щоб я зайшла до тебе
і провідала тебе, поспілкувалася".
Та, кажу, заходь.
Юля протягом усього часу підтримувала зв'язок і так дружили-дружили.
І однієї прогулянки зі старшим сином
мені вистачило, щоб я побачив, як Юля ставиться до дітей.
Я розумів, що як вона ставиться до свого,
вже нашого тепер старшого сина, я розумів,
як вона буде ставитися до нашої спільної дитини.
Потім я зробив пропозицію,
через 3 місяці після спільного життя.
Вже потім - народження меншого і щасливе сімейне життя.
Я до Юлі кажу, що якби я знав,
що зі мною станеться
отак, як сталося, то я б на міну раніше наступив.
Олександр Гончаров запропонував
з перших наших днів знайомства
спробувати себе в проєкті "Ігри героїв".
Це така психологічно-фізична реабілітація.
Через 9 місяців після поранення я прийшов
і переміг у змаганнях,
та ще й у людей, які дуже довго на протезах.
Після того в голові така ідея зародилася,
що моїм прагненням жити можна мотивувати людей важкопоранених.
Це не секрет: не всім вдається так швидко
вийти з цього шоку.
Ідея з рекордом по літаку якраз і була
спрямована на те, що
це буде щось неймовірне, щось дійсно мотивуюче,
класне, хардкорне, але при тому це має бути окрема категорія.
Я 2 грудня 2021 року встановив
національний рекорд України
в номінації "Тяга Ан-26 вагою 16 тонн
людиною з інвалідністю ІІ групи на протезі".
Зараз знову з’явилися можливості тренуватися
і тим самим мотивувати
важкопоранених бійців знову.
Тому що їх надзвичайно велика кількість,
їх збільшилося, мабуть, у разів 6-7,
якщо не більше.
І їх потрібно піднімати на ноги,
якось говорити, показувати.
24 лютого застало нас у Харкові.
О 4:30-4:32 будить тесть і каже, що щось бахкає.
Залітає слідом теща і каже: почалася війна.
Перше рішення - це було
якомога швидше вивезти родину
у максимально безпечне місце,
а вже потім повертатися.
Це в мене крутилося в голові відразу,
як перші вибухи я почув,
що потрібно знову повертатися.
1 березня я повернувся вже у Харків.
Скажімо так, iз корабля на бал -
відразу на Північну Салтівку, в епіцентр.
Наше завдання на Салтівці було
чекати колони росіян, щоб їх знищувати
і вести вже вуличні бої.
Вони постійно утюжили артилерією,
не соромилися.
Постійно, постійно, постійно, щодня.
Мені ніяк не заважало повернутися з протезом.
Мене більше хвилювало те, що на той момент
протез, на якому я повернувся, був купальним.
Купальний – це означає тільки ходити і купатися.
Бігати на ньому не можна, бо там м’яка підошва.
Але для себе я зрозумів, що
на купальній нозі можна бігати.
Коли на штурмі танк стріляв в упор
і будиночки розліталися, як карткові,
то на цій нозі можна було бігати.
Бігалося аж бігом.
Якась відстрочка або "білий квиток",
як це називається,
у мене була, тому що в мене
є свідоцтво про хворобу.
Там написано чорним по білому,
що я непридатний.
У військовий час обмежено приданий, але
покинути територію країни і так далі я можу
у будь-який момент.
Такою вагомою причиною повернутися було,
коли ракети прилітали по пологових будинках,
по школах і так далі,
по цивільному населенню, я розумів, що це планомірне знищення нашої нації.
І тут немає нічого іншого, тільки йти
в епіцентр бою
і захищати, стримувати. Або ми виживемо,
або нас всіх вб’ють.
Можна втекти від усього, але не від своєї совісті.
Я розумів, що коли з Харкова
от тільки-тільки виїжджав,
евакуював родину, в голові таке питання стояло:
"А для чого ти, Ромо, це все починав?"
Тобто навіщо ти пішов на фронт добровольцем,
навіщо втратив ногу, щоб зараз
просто взяти і втекти?
А навіщо ти давав присягу, навіщо ти
хоронив своїх братів по зброї?
Навіщо це все? Щоб зараз взяти і поїхати, втекти?
Так не може бути.
Потім вже нас оформили
у спецпідрозділ "Кракен" харківський.
А потім ми вже перевелися у Збройні сили України, наразі у 92-гу бригаду.
На даний момент це
максимально широкий потік роботи:
від інструктажів десь на полігонах,
на якихось лекціях до якогось забезпечення, волонтерської діяльності.
Наш фронт зараз - це вся країна.
Увесь світ зараз має об’єднатися
проти цього ворога,
тому що дійсно ворог кровожерливий
і ненажерливий.
Великий збирач земель...
Я думаю, що після України
були плани рухатися далі на Європу.
Імперія живе за рахунок війни.
І ми зараз стоїмо як щит для цієї Європи
і для всього цивілізованого світу.
Тут живуть вільні, незалежні люди, які будуть битися за свою землю.
Ми переможемо. Все буде добре.